[Music]
we all know the world is generating data
more than ever so how do we make sense
of this data the traditional data
warehouses were not designed to handle
this exclusive growth in data so as we
see the data volume to increase the
complexity to increase and the number of
use cases around the data to grow
enterprises needs actionable insights so
what do we mean by actionable insights
as the cost of storage and data
processing reduce enterprises want to
process store and analyze all the data
sets internal and external to their
organization the modern data warehouse
also needs to reflect the current state
of business that means you need to act
in real time you need to make those
decisions in real time we don't need a
data warehouse which takes like weeks or
even months to you know get the software
install or even the hardware provision
we also want the insights to be
available to the business users in their
hands so that enterprises move more
towards you know data-driven
decision-making and last but not least
we need security and governance so we
basically want to have the data
accessible to the right stakeholders
internal and external to the
organization's now this statement still
holds true however as the demand for new
data types new use cases and the
complexity has come in over the period
of few years the data warehouse
architecture needs to evolve to meet
this demands in both distributed and
centralized solutions so if we look over
the last two decades basically you know
enterprises started using data warehouse
more from an operational reporting
purposes and then we had you know cell
service BI coming in and over the
decade there has been a huge shift
towards data mining AI and ml so as
businesses inspire to be data-driven
this requires the data warehouse to
support their machine learning and
initiatives so we all need the data
warehouse of future but what worries us
we need to remember that data
warehousing is not a use case data
warehousing is a solution that enables
higher order use cases to make the
businesses data-driven and these are
some of the common challenges which we
see enterprises and businesses face you
know
while managing their data warehouse or
even grow their data warehouse so it's
time now to modernize your data
warehouse with bigquery if you haven't
already
so basically bigquery is Google flouts
enterprise data warehouse it scales from
gigabytes to petabytes
there are numerous features of bigquery
to call out out of which you know there
are few unique features which we have
listed out there with my experience
working with all these large digital
enterprises we have seen them see a lot
of value with real-time analytics
because bigquery natively supports
real-time analytics and you can
basically stream your data all the way
into bigquery and make all those
real-time business decisions so the
challenges which I just showed you in
the slide before bigquery enables us to
overcome those challenges by offering
scalability simplicity security and a
TCO for all kinds of business businesses
no matter
small or large in terms of architecture
which most of you might be familiar it's
fully managed and server lists the
storage and compute are decoupled so
that they scale independently on demand
this basically offers immense
flexibility and control for the
enterprise's and you don't need high
compute resources to keep running 24 by
7 and this is very different from the
traditional node based
and NPP data warehouses so if I have to
summarize what break query brings to the
table it gives you a modern data
warehouse and basically it's focused on
these six key areas with that I would
like to introduce Zaki from go check to
share his experience and go Jack's
experience building the data warehouses
and using bigquery thank you go ruff
hello everyone thank you for joining our
session today so I am Zakir and I work
as a data engineer at kojic and here I
was like to share with experience in
building our data warehouse well we also
do our international Asian before okay
has anyone of you heard about coaching
before you can raise your him oh wow
cool thank you okay so go check is a
technology company in Indonesia that
aims to improve people's quality of life
and then kucik was started in 2010
actually not as a technology company but
as a all center for motorbike surface
motorbike taxi service called object so
the idea of having object taking
passengers around moving things around
is very powerful that we in 2015 are
able to launch our three first digital
digital products called caride Kosan and
go shop all centered around moving
people and things around and people like
our products a lot so in 2016 we are
able to expand our products to many
other kind of services like lifestyle
Digital payment and entertainment and
many others so those many
products has empowered people in
Indonesia so their quality of life has
improved and then we are having very
successful businesses so that in 2018 we
begin our international expansion to
countries in Southeast Asia okay so we
have so many products here you can see
we have cool right blue car for
transport services we have cosine and
goo box for logistic services we have
lifestyle services like go massage GU
glam and we have also go clean and many
others we have also go pay for payment
so we're having that many products in a
single applications people likes to call
as a super app company and all of those
products are very nice because it they
brings convenience to people while also
empowering the drivers empowering the
surface providers so they can get living
[Music]
ok this is our global footprint so we
have expanded to four countries in
Southeast Asia Vietnam Thailand
Singapore and soon we also expanding to
other countries so in those countries we
operating in essentially 204 cities in
Southeast Asia and operating in those
cities our application has to has been
downloaded more than 130 million times
and we also empowers more than 400,000
merchants and more than 2 millions
drivers essentially generating more than
100 million bookings
okay so we move on to our data warehouse
architecture so this is our data
architecture using GCP we can see that
we have many many Google products there
we use bigquery for our data warehouse
we use cloud storage for our data Lake
and then data procure Burnet is data
flow for our alt attribute and also like
composer stackdriver for operations and
monitoring so we already have know that
we we have to offer so many services in
for so many kind of pieces different
businesses so our data warehouse has the
requirement to fulfill all of the the
different businesses has to support
range of different kind of businesses so
Google products has helped us in
building our data warehouse we can
fulfill all the requirements supporting
many different teams probably with
different kind of setups in each team in
its team can have like Postgres cluster
MySQL cluster and then they can have a
user tracking system using that part
that party platform so all the Google
products has helped us in building our
data warehouse and data warehouse has
called as a multi product at our house
because we have to support that many
kind of products okay this is the
current statistic of our data warehouse
in in the end of q1 of 2019 we can see
here that our data volume is increasing
more than 30 percent in each month and
then
because of many and many data has
ingested to our data warehouse many
people can use the data for insights for
analytics so they can generate more than
13-thousand dashboard the dashboard
supports from high level like strategic
team doing doing more strategic
decision-making until operation level
solving passengers of our driver
challenge or driver case and problems so
the most important metric of our data
warehouse is this the growing numbers of
bigquery user so our data warehouse
using bigquery and then we can see that
in the end of q1 2019 we have two
thousand and one hundred active users of
bigquery this is it is the three times
more three times the number of the user
in mid 2018 this is the period we do our
global expansion and then more and more
people rely on data when making decision
and then here comes the challenge
actually when people wants to develop
ETL jobs when people wants to schedule
their their analytics queries people
realize heavily on our bi engineer to do
that we publicize heavily on our bi
engineer to create a healthy jobs and
the our bi engineers capacity is is
limited and more and more requests
coming beyond our p ing nurse capacities
and then
here comes the other challenge while we
are undergoing very fast growth we have
to we have to move us and then to
international expansion so we have to
keep up with our growth while we also
have to support with global expansion we
have to expand our data warehouse to
countries in Southeast Asia and then we
are very lucky because the GCP products
that empowers us has helped us in many
ways to support with with our data
warehouse but yeah improvement can be
made improvement can always be made
while we have operating and can support
all of those use cases we realize that
our current set up is not the most
efficient set up we can we can we can do
more and more things to improve our
efficiencies ok so we come with several
questions that we asked to ourself how
can we survive the global expansion
several questions that we essentially
have to solve in a short period of time
so the first question is how can we
extend the data warehouse to countries
in Southeast Asia and set up some GCP
projects faster and easier for those for
those extension and the second question
is how can we manage user access so when
we know that a number of our data
warehouse is growing the thing that will
directly impact us
how to manage those user access if we
don't mean it user access better we will
we will have difficulties in managing
all of those access and then the third
question is how can we make the LT LT
job development less depending on our bi
engineers and how can we make the
development friendlier and then oh well
usually the one that develops the LD job
is VI engineer how can we make the
development friendlier to non bi
engineers like analyst like product
managers or even operation team wants to
do some queries to solve people's
problem and then the last question is
how can we maintain users confidence to
data so we don't want users to always
worry about what is the quality of data
it is data good to use now or what what
the things that I need to check to
ensure that the data can be used by me
okay so the first thing that we do
bye-bye
setting up the GCP project faster is
expressing all the configuration in
infrastructure as code so we want our
data warehouse to be extended to each
countries in Southeast Asia some of them
will have common configuration some of
them will have specific configuration
and then those configuration can include
data modelling layers Express in GCS GCS
bucket and bigquery data set and many
other
decorations like the composer instances
the kubernetes for executing the reality
jobs so how can we set up the project
faster so here we are using terraform so
one platform to to help us expressing
our configuration as code and then the
nice thing about expressing the
configuration using infrastructure as
code is we can set up faster and then by
having the set up faster we can then we
can do experimenting with different kind
of setup so we want to experiment with
Vietnam for example we can do this data
modeling we can do this
composer we can do this a kubernetes
cluster is enough or not so we can just
express all the configuration using
tariffs on plan and terraform apply and
then the projects are there we can
experiment with it and then if we are
done and we are not satisfied with the
settings we can use the reformed this
destroy to delete the projects and we
can repeat with other configuration and
then the other nice thing is all the
configuration is stated explicitly in
one file or probably two file so we can
we can share the configuration and
everybody can see it so we can have the
common understandings about how the how
the settings of our data warehouse
and then the second part is how can we
better manage our user access to data so
we built a tool called that appear so
that off pier will assist us in built-in
help user onboard with the data
warehouse so previously previously user
request access to us by using email or
coming to our desk directly like it's
not scalable to do that way every time
we have we get emails to to give to give
them access and then every time we do
some work and then some people just come
and then hey give me give me access to
this data set and then we have
conversation and then yeah we lost the
productivity so we built this data pier
so people that need access only open
that appear and then they can request
access in that in the data beer
dashboard and then in the data where
people will also see this data set is a
can be accessed by this Google Groups
and then they can join some Google
groups that has access to data set so we
manage user access using Google Groups
and then we develop the tools using
Google I am API the backend for our two
is Google I am API the third thing that
helps us very much to boost our
productivity in developing reality job
is having having a tools that helps
helps people they can set their own ult
ult jobs so
we think that SQL is a very nice thing
we can express transformation in SQL
because SQL is simple straightforward
and then it's very intuitive so we move
from good Center the god-centered
transformation into SQL based
transformation so when people knows at
ul by doing analysis we can teach them
SQL easier then teach them how to code
so well they know well they know SQL
they can set their their their own
reality jobs by by using the tools so
people that have the query only needs to
install our optimal CLI tools and then
submit the query SQL query and then to
select what is the destination that a
certain table and then and then
determine what is the what is the
schedule for the job and then the
optimal stores will take care of the
rest everything done automated and then
people will will also knows what is the
the result of the execution and then the
fourth thing that we build is data
quality service so we have the problems
of convincing people that this data this
table is good to use and then we don't
want to we don't want them to always
worry about data quality of the data we
don't want them to be surprised in so
late time because their data has
completely issues has uniqueness issues
so we built an out
data quality service that helps people
with with checking the data quality of
the yeah the quality of data and we
implement the data quality service in in
Google Google products like kubernetes
and then composer to schedule - schedule
the execution of data quality profiling
so when people finish with finish with
creating the health LD jobs they can
continue with creating data quality
specification like for this column's
what is the threshold for completeness
what is the threshold for uniqueness so
they can submit the the the data quality
specification into into repo so the
tools will get the data quality
specification compiles it and then this
run the data quality profiling based on
the specification and then the data
quality data quality assessment is done
immediately after after the execution of
its ETL jobs so people will always know
what is the quality of the data and then
will can get alert if some columns is
not not complete enough or or some keys
is not unique and then but still problem
with data is still there so what is
problem with data actually so we already
know that yeah data warehouse is data
warehouse and then if data comes to us
how can we create such a such a single
version of truth how can we create a
table
authoritative table that single table
can be used by many people for analytics
for reporting so people don't have to
compare one source of data to other
source of data because yeah
too many data source to be used so the
other thing is how can we make sure that
also the single version of truth is rich
in context so for example in go check we
have we have booking data with many
dimensions like pickup drop-off the
duration and the even locks so the other
problem is how can we structure and
model the data so luckily bickering has
some nice features that helps us with
such problem that solve our our our
problem with with those features and
then here we have even that will shows
us tells us how can we how can we
structure the data in our data warehouse
using those feature so we can get the
best of bigquery in in solving our
problems even please come
afternoon it's always interesting doing
like a session at 4:00 p.m. right before
do you guys know the actress coming on
tonight who's attending the party later
on tonight anyone know who the act is
Gwen Stefani right so I'm literally the
gatekeeper between you and you and Gwen
Stefani which is which is tough she's a
lot better of a singer than I am so I
can promise you that but it has a guest
that I can help you out with data
warehousing a little bit better than
chica so the problem of data is still
there if you find him switching back to
the slides I'll do the demo just a
little bit later so I've been at Google
for years and one of the problems I
really really like tackling I'm a
technical curriculum developer it's
taking bigquery and the things that it
can do that seem like magic like
including many different types of data
petabytes of Records millions of
different events all inside of one plays
and making it accessible to everybody
I'm going to show you just a little bit
of a snippet of some code that you can
see I'll provide you the code this
session is being recorded also we're
gonna be doing a hands-on lab after this
sessions if you really want to get into
the granular details you can follow me
back to Moscow and yourself but when I
started my career you know 15 years ago
teaching sequel one of the biggest
things that was taught to me I'm going
to ask you for the for the answer for it
is if you have data that's in four
different places you have events you
have orders your pickups or drop-offs
that's what we call normalize data
structure raise your hand if you work
with databases before you've heard of
normalization raise your hand if you've
worked with bigquery before as well
awesome keep your hands raised if you
work with arrays inside of bigquery or
JSON data okay cool so I'll speed
through this a little bit so the
constant struggle is do we split our
data across many different tables inside
of a sequel what do you have to do as
API analyst to bring all those back
together you gotta join them all back
together right it's everyone's sequel
101 you absolutely hate that stuff or do
you dump it all in one big table and you
have data issues one fact in one play
it's not so much in repeat them so since
you've worked with or you've heard of
arrays before one of the really cool
data types that's natively supported
inside of bigquery is the array so you
have object-oriented programmers the
like obviously yeah I want to do a raise
for everything and you have sequel
developers saying
whoa we're rows and columns based keep
your arrays to yourself bigquery is a
data warehouse as a data platform can
support both I'm going to walk through
examples of what's really beneficial of
storing your data and that's the
repeated format this is go jack Zacky
and Gaurav provided me with an awesome
table this is a bookings table so Zaki
mentioned you have lots of different
information about go jack bookings like
motorcycle ride shares that are all
inside of one table now all that
different context from 15 different
tables is all in one so if you notice it
looks really strange if you've never
seen arrays inside of bigquery before so
this is actually only four rows of data
on this screenshot yeah there's a
thousand or so in totally in bigquery
but what's interesting is that you see
that there's a status field and a time
field for arrays that look like there
are four rows of data inside of that
first one that's in array of data so if
you're familiar with like arrays it's
the bracket essentially bigquery
visually breaks that out for you but
technically behind the scenes it's still
in those brackets and it's gonna get
really interesting when you see the demo
of how to work with that natively
supports that'sthat's one data type and
you'll see how we work with those in
just a minute the other data type that's
interesting if you're looking at the top
and you're like I'm familiar in sequel
with an alias like naming a field
something else what on earth is events
dot something pick up dot something
destination dot something it almost
looks like you've got six or four
different tables all inside of one the
structure and this is not specific to
bigquery this is just generally part of
sequel it's supporting bigquery it's
called a struct and short for structure
you combine both of them together and
you can have really wide tables a struct
is kind of like a pre joined table
inside of bigquery so you both get the
width of having information on events
pickup destination I'm gonna show you an
example data set that as over 30 structs
in it that's the Google Analytics schema
and you get the granularity of having
one row technically represents one order
like a rideshare pickup or something
like that but within one row you can
have extreme glory annular ta at the
array level where there's many different
hats things happening with one order so
your queries can get at the high level
can
star from all orders sure I got four
orders or I could look deep into the
array values there without having to
worry about data stored and in in a
repeated fashion like I truly do you
normalize alright so a little bit of a
practice for you a question
I'm a technical developer you're not
gonna leave here without a quiz and we
definitely have some cool
lab promotions for you as well in a
schema inside of bigquery if you work a
big word before you've seen this before
yell out maybe one or a couple of the
structs how do you how do you know
whether that's a struct you're looking
for a data type of record whenever you
see record in somebody's skin like well
this person's using struts yelling out
event events one give me another one
pickup cool what else if you will leave
this class with nothing else
understanding this schema and the fact
that whoever has created that table that
you've inherited is using semi
structured data either like nested or
repeated especially when you raise your
end if you work with JSON data before I
never know if it's JSON or JSON data
that's another argument for a different
time ingesting that in you're definitely
get some nested repeated values you can
actually nest values 15 layers deep the
computer can handle it mentally a human
if you gave them 15 essentially tabs and
a data set your bi n else might get
really mad all right so you're exactly
right these are essentially kind of like
four other tables that are pre joined
into their pre join you can think for a
huge performance benefit means that you
actually can get a lot of performance
not having to run that join behind the
scenes which is cool so my sequel
Postgres cloud sequel that's
transactional that's 80% writes 20%
reads bigquery data warehouse you're
doing the majority 80% reads instead of
riots it's better to have that data
stored inside of one table not doing
performance hits on joins all right now
look at the mode and then find me the
array or arrays you guys are fast
that's exactly right the events have
that double level of granularity the
rows of this table yes they are on the
order level when you look at Google
Analytics it's on this session level but
within each of those different rows you
can get at extreme granularity by
nesting
in array which is great but when you
write sequel against an array
unless you're experienced with it what
you're gonna see in the demo it's really
really painful so quick recap before the
demo anytime you see a record that
immediately means a struct struct is not
specific to bigquery
but it's natively supported anytime you
see repeated in the mode that means it's
an array you don't have to have a struct
to have an array but if you have you can
nest arrays with instructs for example
the events is a struct as you see here
that doesn't mean it has to be like
there are other things in here that
aren't repeated like the pickup latitude
and pickup longitude unless you're
changing your motorcycle ride mid trip
there's no need to have that be a race
that's thunder right it's just a normal
struct but the first one it's an event
as many different things that can happen
over the course of the order rider
picked up dropped off charge reversed
that type of stuff that's an array all
right let's take a look at what this
actually looks like inside of code so
we're inside a bigquery you all are
familiar with bigquery before if you're
not petabyte scale data analytics
platform you can just throw arbitrary
amounts of sequel against it if you're
gonna take a screenshot of one slide
what I did for those people who want to
leave earlier in Katz's qantas gwen
stefani
i want you to take a screenshot of this
these are all the free links that you
should know about this session has a
Dory which is essentially a question and
answer if we don't get to your question
at the end I want you to post that
question on there and then later on
tonight or later on this week if you
have a complicated data question you
want to know a cool link to a lab I want
you to post that question in there and
Gaurav zakir and i will definitely
answer it next thing all the code that
you learned here I've spent the last
year of my life
building out interactive labs to get you
from a blank canvas in bigquery to
building machine learning models to
building nested repeated data structures
performance optimizing your queries and
get them for free which is pretty cool
so that's that free labs if you want to
hear more of my voice you can actually
take the Coursera course and you get a
month free TL DR I don't want to spend
too much time to advertising but if you
don't get what you want out of this
session you're welcome to self-study
with the labs come back with me to
Moscone cells after this we're gonna be
working through one of them so inside of
bigquery zaki was kind enough sake and
the team at go-jek were kind enough to
give us a table inside a bit quite a
cool thing that you can do and I'll
provide this code to all of you is if
somebody gives you a table
cool thing if you've never seen this
before what on earth you can actually
select the entire biome I'm holding down
the command key or the Windows key and
you can actually highlight all the data
sets that are inside of a corner it's
kind of cool so inside of there
generally we advise against
don't let your bi analyst do select star
from a table limit 10 bigquery already
stores a lot of that metadata in a
preview so I don't even need to write
any sequel to see what the data is in
there it's a recap you can click on a
table name you can look at the metadata
and this is exactly where I took this
screenshot from for the slides and
you're going whoa it's one row but it's
three things now that you know that it's
an array of different values for
timestamps you're like okay cool that's
not too bad now what I want to do is I
want to just get all the orders and all
the different statuses for those orders
so I'm querying this and you can see how
this might potentially blow up and I'm
gonna query these so what's that gonna
look like well you saw all about a big
red exclamation mark what so this is a
huge takeaway for the next five minutes
of this lecture is anytime you see this
error you can google it it'll probably
take to a video to do this session or
the documentation don't be afraid when
you're you're literally doing just what
it seems like a simple sequel query but
all that means is that this person right
here is an array and we need to
essentially unpack that array back into
rows and columns before we can operate
on it bigquery will definitely take your
array ingest at no problems but before
we do that let's talk about how arrays
work inside a bigquery
if you're familiar with object-oriented
on and if you're a data analyst data
engineer you're definitely to see them a
lot in your data warehouse an array it's
an ordered set of values they must share
a data type so here's just an array of
strings no big deal we just passed in a
bunch of fruit and we stored a dozen
array we're specifying an array here and
we got one row we got four things in
that a row now I can also infer it so I
don't tell it's I don't tell it the view
this is a string value but it
automatically just knows that those
that's gonna be an array what are some
cool things that you can do with an
arrays want you to intern array format
you want to particularly say hey I'm
gonna find the second element in the
array who can tell me is brave enough to
shout
never be recorded on YouTube that which
what is it what are we gonna return here
when I run this I've got a raspberry
blackberry strawberry cherry and I've
got offset of two in there look on line
41 before you shout out what are you
saying hands up if you think cherry
hands up if you think raspberry what
about blackberry oh you all are too
smart what about strawberry yeah all
right yeah you definitely are earning
you're earning your your alcoholic
beverages later it is zero index yes
exactly so if you didn't want to do
offset you could do ordinal how about
now yell it out what are we gonna return
now
yeah it's precisely right so you can do
cool things with arrays you can just
look at one value zoom in on just one
particular value what about I want to do
I want to see hey how many things are in
that array I can do a ray length there's
a ton of array functions I'm just
showing you the tip of the iceberg of
some of them the most most common
aggregations you have four items in your
cart now here's the issue we saw
different levels of granularity in the
bookings this is the same thing here I
can't run a where clause against a
typical where Clause select start from
where against this item there are two
different levels of granularity right
how do I work with arrays well let's go
back to the go-jek example taking a look
at the preview we're gonna look at the
payment method one insight always start
with a good question write all data
analysis begins with a good question
cash cash cash is cash the most popular
method for the orders well we can write
as some very simple sequel query we're
just gonna say countif order is by the
payment method group it by we're not
even touching the array values and you
get the answer back for there so like I
could cool this is basic sequel we can
see as an inside most of the people in
this demo table pay with cash and then
the second highest is go pay the native
app based payment not a problem we're
not touching any array values all right
well I'm gonna go back into the table
and there's a bunch of interesting
status fields associated with an order
driver canceled created driver found if
you're familiar with sequel one of the
easiest ways you can get a distinct list
of values is
select distinct so select distinct
status if someone comes along you with
this query you might just look at Nicole
that's absolutely gonna run fine boom
you're gonna get this error immediately
you're gonna get angry and don't worry
about it but I want you to train your
mind as soon as you see array I want you
to memorize this word on Nest's if you
ever get an array and you need to unpack
it the fancy way that we decided to call
it is unnecessary so once we break that
array apart it's gonna look like this
normal sequel runs fine you can see that
there are let's see nine unique statuses
this doesn't give us too much context
let's add an additional aggregated field
let's just say hey let's do a count of
the order is buying each of the distinct
statuses that were in there now a note
let's do a pause here so what you've
done event is normally stored like this
one two three four five that's a normal
array nested unnecessarily devilish
thing you can do in your code and I
don't recommend it is essentially this
in my mind conceptionally is very
different this nested this unnecessary a
turn them from line 106 to the rest
don't give them the same alias it's
incredibly confusing and one of the best
ways you can help out your fellow
programmers on nested array you can
leave it whatever you want just make it
really obvious which one is which
because that's the one you actually have
as your alias when you're pulling it
from there and you can see that that
works just fine let's see the total
amount of status if I'm gonna rename it
on the fly for a demo I need to rename
it in all places so that's the note that
I have they're always rename it as
something different and this is
fundamentally what's going on nested
regular rows and columns you can go
crazy with Siegel on it so you can see
the majority here we just have the quick
insight majority of orders have the
status driver found and then created
picked up completed customer cancelled
link it to a dashboard if you on you
actually explore directly in data studio
I'm not going to show you that right now
but you can link a table directly to
into data studio all right I do want to
leave a little bit of time at the end so
one of the things you might be asking is
when you get access to this code hey
Evan I don't have go check that booking
table because it's a sample but what you
do have is you have the Google Analytics
schema and if you think two or three
structs inside of a table is a lot if
you and this is all in the bigquery
public data there's over 130 bigquery
public data sets for you to play with
one of them or if you have your own
Google Analytics account it's this
Google Analytics sample any guesses on
how many and you might have already seen
the answer how many structs are in the
Google Analytics schema how wide is this
schema I just throw out a number one two
three seven let's see let's see let's
put what we're doing in search oh it's
already cheated what wording is search
for for the for the type in a search for
record there's 32 structs inside the
Google Analytics key one that's
essentially 32 pieces of context other
tables that are jammed in there that's
because there's a lot of data that's
collected for your visitors for your
e-commerce website and you can see you
can even nest Struck's hits dot product
dot is impression hits thought event
info event category so you can get a
really really what's called denormalized
or gigantic singular table for reporting
insights and that's exactly how Google
Analytics is set up and that's the data
set that you can experiment with this
you can actually I said before you can
go 15 deep so if you wanted to fix this
query for example page title is our
array what you would need to do is hits
your unnecessary thing don't confuse
everybody
and then you'll be able to select from
it and you get some really cool data
that's returned so why are you a lot of
you might be wondering I'm never gonna
come across in that certain fields I
don't have any JSON data ha ha you will
soon because if you're building a
classification model inside a big query
which now you can do with just two lines
of code create Model Model type
classification using logistic regression
a little bit outside the scope of this
talk but what you're gonna get back and
this is what the lab is gonna be a 5
o'clock and musk on yourself you're
gonna get back something bigquery is
gonna say hey you remember that talk
hopefully didn't hopefully didn't sleep
through it it's gonna give you back for
example this problem is whether or not a
visitor who visits your website is gonna
buy or not buy and a return visit it
could be whatever a problem that you
want but for a classification model each
of those classes yes they will buy no
they won't buy is gonna return back in
an array and it's gonna give you a
confidence 55% I'm sure 44% I'm I'm not
sure and again what's still in Maine
huge if you're working with arrays as
soon as you see that word array inside
of bigquery what's that other word it
starts with a you that you should
immediately memorize no unnecessary at
up for questions so this is the example
of the the final final result where you
can do cool things like tell I want the
machine learning model does it tell me
its highest predictions where they're
gonna come back you have to break that
array apart and then you can do normal
sequel and get hey I'm 80% sure this
person is going to come back and buy
from our website now if you want to know
how to create models that's the next
session at 5:00 and Moscone south big
query ml is really really cool or if you
want to get additional practice I'm
working with arrays we did a full day
bootcamp predicting NCAA March Madness
for men's and women's who's gonna be the
final teams that are gonna make it we
created an entire lab on machine
learning for that one that's this quest
we have an entire lab on loading in and
querying JSON data essentially this demo
but in a two hour really comprehensive
lab and then this lab is gonna be the
one that would be running a little bit
later on tonight or you can take these
at your leisure
[Music]